همم تنضم الينا في هذه النافذه وزيره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه كيف عفوا الهولنديه كيف
اهلا وسهلا بك
سيده قيصر رئيس وزراء هولندا كان في كييف
والتقى المسؤولين الاوكرانيين بخصوص دعم
اوكرانيا حدثين ما الذي جرى بين رئيس
الوزراء الهولندي والمسؤولين الاوكرانيين
نعم تماما ورئيس وزرائنا زرع كييف مجددا
اعتقد انه لدينا علاقات قويه مع اوكرانيا
ليس فقط الان خلال الحرب وانما كذلك قبل
الحرب لقد اكدنا على دعمنا لاوكرانيا اذا
اوكرانيا بامكانها ان تعتمد على هولندا من
اجل المساعدات العسكريه التدريب والذخيره
وننسق ذلك مع شركاء والحلفاء لان هناك
مساله مهمه بالنسبه لنا روسيا ليس
بامكانها ان تفوز بحرب العدوان هاته لابد
من احترام سياده اوكرانيا وهذا هو المؤشر
الذي نرسله الى كوتي ولبقيه العالم كذلك
لان الحرب هي تجري في اوكرانيا مع
التابعات والنتائج والدمار الذي لحق
باوكرانيا وهذه كذلك اشاره لبقيه العالم
لابد ان نقف لان هذا الامر لا يحدث فقط في
اوكرانيا وانما في المناطق اخرى لذلك لابد
ان نحترم سياده ووحده اراضي اوكرانيا وهذا
الامر هو محزن انه في 2023 نجد هذه الامور
تجري رساله
بامكانكم ان تعتمدوا علينا
هولندا بتقديم دبابات
لاوكرانيا اين وصلت هذه المساله
هذا الامر هو مهم ان الولايات المتحده
المملكه المتحده والمانيا قررت ان ترسل
كذلك الدبابات الى اوكرانيا لقد قمنا
بشيئين اثنين نحن مع الولايات المتحده
وجمهوريه التشيك نحن
سندعم
هي الدبابات التي كانت تستخدم ونحن كذلك
نزود بهذه الدبابات التي تعتبر الدبابات
التي تعتبر مهمه والتي هي تم احداثها
لتكون جاهزه بالنسبه
للمعركه لدينا ما يسمى بليو تو كذلك
والمملكه الهولنديه تقول اننا سنوفر كذلك
التدريب والذخيره اللازمه حتى يتسنى
لاوكرانيا ان تستخدم هذه المعدات في
الاشهر القادمه
طيب في الاشهر القادمه سيمكن لاوكرانيا ان
تستخدم كل هذه المعدات
كيف تفسرين سيد كايسا انه بعد مرور سنه
يعني تقريبا سنه من عمر هذه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا الرغم كل هذا الدعم رغم كل
هذا الحشد ما زالت لم تحسم المعركه لصالح
اوكرانيا
بامكاننا كذلك ان ندير المساله اذا لم نكن
قد بعثنا الكثير من المساعدات ربما
العمليه والعالم كان قد عان كثيرا وان
الجهه المعتديه كانت لتفوز اوكرانيا بلاء
حسنا وتعالي لكن بامكاننا فقط ان تفوز اذا
ما كانت تعتمد على شركائها من اجل المعدات
والتدريب لماذا هذا الامر هو محزن مضي سنه
واحده كامله واسعه النطاق نرى ان الجهه
المعتديه لا تحقق الاهداف التي بدات الحرب
من اجلها وهذا بحد ذاته لا نعرف لا نعرف
طبعا ما سيحدث في الاشهر القادمه لكن نامل
بان اوكرانيا تكون قادره بان تقاوم روسيا
وان تكون قادره على استعاده اراضيها التي
هي اراضي مستحق لها وفي الان ذاته نرفضائع
كثيره ترتكب في اوكرانيا الكثير من
الاشخاص يفقدون ارواحهم في اوكرانيا لكن
الجواب الوحيد هو ان توقف روسيا الحرب غدا
اذا ما توقفت اوكرانيا
فان المساله ستكون مختلفه على الرغم من
انه لا اعتقد اي شخص منا يريد ان تكون هذه
الحرب او تندلع هذه الحرب اذن سنه كامله
مرت
واوكرانيا تقاوم وتصبح اقوى فاقوى وتعتمد
على شركائها ونامل ان هذا الامر سيكون الى
سبيل الى الامام من اجل الوصول الى نهايه
الحرب وان تكون لدينا اوكرانيا ذات سياده
كيسه وزيره الدفاع الهولنديه شكرا جزيلا
لك ثان